Congrats to the Baltimore Ravens you
guys suck you won the sugar coffee on a
Tuesday and vlog 48 so when I finished
the sixth grade and was ready to make
the big move to junior high my parents
said you know Evan elementary school was
easy but next year junior high it's not
going to be so easy next year is gonna
be hard so I steal my 11 year old self
and brace for junior high with a certain
fear and expectation that life had so
far been a light breeze but now that was
over there was going to be a certain
fundamental change in things and that
change would be for the worse well
seventh grade came in seventh grade went
and when I opened my eyes everything was
still pretty simple and pretty easy
things really hadn't changed that summer
my parents said you know Evan seventh
grade was easy but eighth grade whoo-hoo
things are gonna get serious now get
ready
eighth grade and went that summer my
parents warned me about high school but
by that time I had come to believe that
they were pretty unreliable sources in
this particular field nonetheless they
kept saying so every year through high
school and college and every year I
couldn't help but almost believe but
every year they were wrong now to be
very clear I am not implying in any way
that I'm gifted or smarter than the
average person the whole point of the
nerdwriter
is that I'm not but I never did do much
work in school I never did try very hard
I found despite my parents warnings that
I didn't need to I often joke with
friends that in school I studied the
teachers and not the subjects and it's
true if I deconstructed the
personalities of the grade givers of how
they were to test and awarded points I
could construct my own personality and
word my own answers in a way that was
complimentary and that's how I got
through I think I saw even at a young
age that reality was fluid it was in
constant which made it flexible a huge
number of the rules of society were
convention they were as alterable as
people were persuadable at the risk of
self psychoanalysis I think this comes
in large part from my dad who is in a
word incorrigible
he's a born Hagler unwilling to believe
that something can't be done until he's
tried it himself it's a great quality
but enough about me is this
just all in my head or is there some
truth to this idea well in the end what
we're really talking about is evolution
we're talking about intuition reason
morality we're talking about the way
people were early in Plato's Republic a
dialogue about justice in the perfect
society the precocious young Glaucon
puts a question to Socrates worded in
the popular would you rather style it's
this would you rather be an honest and
fair person and have everyone believe
that you're a liar and a douchebag or
would you rather be a liar and a
douchebag and have everyone believe that
you're a fair and honest and wonderful
person now it's Plato's prerogative to
prove to Glaucon that being good is
better than seeming good that our minds
are perfect reasoning machines meant to
find truth and master the lowly passions
despite the reputational cost and that
in truth is happiness
Clow con like a good little bitch is
eventually brought around but to be fair
Socrates is a master debater and what
he's saying sounds good but the reality
of humanity is somewhat different than
Plato's idea of the truth about us is
that our minds are less equipped for
reasoning than they are for
justification a number of studies by
moral psychologists like Robert Zions
Howard Margolis and Jonathan Haidt show
us that intuitions and emotions rule
that when in contact with anything we
react instantaneously for or against
that thing and our reason goes to work
looking not for the truth but for a way
to justify what we've already decide
ever try telling someone they're wrong
about something flat-out well your tone
has already defeated your purpose of
that person senses confrontation their
whole being will turn away from you the
smart little politician in their head
the reason that Plato imagines is
working to find the truth instead goes
to work finding the reasons why you're
wrong we've evolved to become
outstandingly adept at justifying our
intuitions and it explains a lot why we
argue when we're wrong why we forgive
good-looking people their flaws and
vice-versa why we lie and omit and
carefully carve the versions of
ourselves that we show to others simply
the evolutionary advantages of
discovering the truth are less than the
evolutionary advantages of having a good
reputation Glaucon who in the end would
rather be a liar that everyone likes has
got
spend more accurately than even the
great Plato to know these things gives
one a great power you're likely to get
more out of life if like my dad you
haggle with reality addressing someone's
intuitions or emotions will more readily
yield the results that you want from
them people are fluid reality is people
reality is fluid there's an insidious
side to this and I think you can hear it
essentially we are made to be
manipulated and there's no shortage of
that of course in human history probably
in your personal history too but along
with our intuitive desire to get what we
want we are also guided by the intuitive
aversion to harm our reasoning faculty
is not a slave to our emotions but a
politician and the best politicians like
the best people can navigate a fluid
reality of flexible rules seeking ever
subtler ways not to harm the people they
share the world with and you know what
harms people manipulation everybody
thanks for watching don't forget to
follow me on Twitter and Tumblr
links in the description also if you
want to read more about moral psychology
I highly recommend the righteous mind by
Jonathan Haidt it's a great book
extremely well written and you'll learn
a little bit more about why we think the
way we think so read that and I'll see
you next time